good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about strategies on how to
improve your productivity rule number
three is my personal favorite I make
sure to stick around it over to the end
from my take and some special bonus
clips as well and as always as you hear
people saying something that's really
relevant to you please leave it in
comments below put quotes around it too
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
you
how much time does it take to have a
good idea zero how much time does it
take to be creative zero how much time
does it take to be loving and present
with your kids when you tuck them in bed
at night zero those do not require time
they require space if you're wrapped up
around a problem an issue you know
backlog of all kinds of things unhandled
and not inappropriately engaged with
very difficult that have creative ideas
be innovative or be loving and present
you need room oh come on Leonardo da
Vinci had 24 hours mother Teresa had 24
hours Johann Sebastian Bach had 24 hours
you know I know he didn't have whatsapp
but he had 20 kids take your pick you
need room here's how I want you to work
through your day from now on first when
you wake up your goal is not to go to
the computer and check your inbox we've
got to tear you away from the inbox
particularly if you are senior executive
and owner of a business
a person who has major projects that
you're moving forward if you are a
customer service person and your job is
to check email all day then hey I get it
that's okay but for most folks their
real goal is not to check email all day
it's to be productive and get things
done so unless it's your job to be on
the email drip where you respond to
everything within 10 or 15 minutes then
this is really about taking ownership of
your life again and I think those folks
who are in that position will also find
this to be very inspiring and a wise
guide to working more effectively so
let's get to it you know what you do
when you wake up each day let's talk
about productivity in general when you
wake up each day the first thing to do
is not go to the computer the first
thing to do is go exercise go for a walk
take a long shower is to open your body
and engage and in doing that process
wherever it is for you some people it's
a long run
give us a longer shower some people have
to walk around the neighborhood when
you're doing that here's what I want you
ask yourself a couple of simple
questions first I want you to ask
yourself what am i excited about today
or could I create to be excited about
today so what is it I want you to begin
your day with enthusiasm optimism is the
magical formula that creates greater
happiness in our lives to have something
to look forward to steal away someone's
vision for a good future and you'll
quickly see them fall into the
depression but when we have a great
connection to something in the future
that we look forward to even if it's
just this day that creates the charge
within us so walk around take your laps
do whatever you have to do in the
morning but ask yourself what is it that
I'm excited about today or could be
enthusiastic about today second ask what
am i grateful for in life today you know
what am I still appreciative of having
now I know a lot of these videos I'm
talking so fast to you but as you get to
know my work I'm a pretty soulful guy on
I'm I'm an incredibly grateful person
for all that I've been able to create
all you know all the stages I get on all
the people come to our seminars the
brands I've built the opportunities I've
been blessed to have even the challenges
I've been blessed to have and I think
that coming from that place spiritual
each day really opens you up to
something magnificent in the universe
maybe you agree and so ask what kind of
you enthusiastic about what am i
grateful for and then ask third what am
I committed to making happen today no
matter what if we start from those
positions then we're in good then we're
in a good space then I want you to drink
lots of water and have a healthy
breakfast lots of water
healthy breakfast now we can start
thinking about work deal this is the
secret to you performing better we've
got to get you in the right mindset in
the morning we've got to take care of
your physical needs of hydration and
nourishment then walk into the office
then get ready to work point number two
you want to make sure you're producing
the right thing
you could make a ton of decisions check
off a lot of email make a ton of phone
calls and at the end of the day the end
of the weekend does a quarter the end of
the year not have accomplished all that
much at all the way that I get around
that is looking at my list of goals
looking at my list of priorities with a
my list - duze and asking myself which
of these if done would make all of the
other ones easier or unnecessary this is
a great way to narrow your focus to the
most important Domino that when flipped
over will then topple 20 30 40 others
one thing I keep in mind a lot this term
speed job innovation is saying no to a
thousand things and really if you want
to do anything impressive anything
incredible you have to say no to 99% of
what comes at you and that certainly
applies to you know which is effectively
everyone else's agenda for your public
we all have the same 24 hours in the day
and if you're like oh this time I can't
sleep I need to cut back on sleep I need
to do this I need to do that if you
don't have time you don't have priority
that's good your environment is so
important and if you look at be
performers or see producers they really
don't pay a lot of attention to their
environment and so they get very
distracted there's lots of noises their
phones are going off maybe there's news
in the background maybe there's messy
environments all around them maybe
there's toxic people what I'm suggesting
to you is the second piece of technology
to really 100 times your productivity is
this install environments of tight
bubbles of total focus the way I run my
work like on certain days I am very hard
to reach and I challenge you with great
love and respect be very hard to reach
during key times of your week I mean I
see a lot of people and it's not judging
them it's just observing them every time
their phone rings they check or they
have you know these loud notifications
so they're constantly being distracted
and we know what the research says the
research says we spend 2.1 hour
day in distraction we spent and it takes
21 minutes to refocus your focus after
you've been distracted so if you are
being distracted by notifications
checking your phone checking your
Twitter feed checking your Facebook feed
looking on Instagram checking all the
different platforms that is going to
destroy your focus so the second piece
of Technology's create these type
bubbles of total focus and the way I do
it is I have certain days that I label
as creative days and on those creative
days I actually go device free and on
those days I'm very hard to find and on
those days I'm in total solitude and on
those days I go to certain places I
called them my Menlo labs just like
Edison had his Menlo lab and these
places are very minimalist and there's
no one there and that's where I do my
best work so install these type bubbles
of total focus and create these Menlo
labs where you're sort your completely
distraction free and then you will find
your brain will drop from the beta state
into the alpha state where you will do
your best work and get your best ideas
but I think one of the biggest mistakes
that entrepreneurs make especially as
they grow their business or in the
beginning when they're crippled by this
thought of quality work versus just
doing it you know like smart work versus
just work is when you start judging it
too much you start leaving yourself out
of opportunity for serendipity and
upside that you can't see there's been a
lot of things that on paper may look
like busy work going to get you know
just kissing babies and shaking hands or
just replying to everybody on Twitter
things that not everybody thinks is the
best scalable use of my time that has
led to enormous upside because it wasn't
obvious when you first did it including
a video show including ten years ago in
a month sitting upstairs doing a video
show where everybody's like we needed
you that hour to sell wine or to
reorganize our operations why are you
putting a video on YouTube what is you
to like not it it ended up being the
biggest single biggest decision of my
career up to this point transitioning
myself into a media property and a brand
from just being an operator in this
floor
wasn't obvious felt like it could have
been busy work and there's been other
things that I've done like that that
have been busy work you know try to
think of a good example but like a
million things that we've stopped and
started it didn't become real it happens
with us every day in our team so so I
think that on I think you don't always
know I think you find out after the fact
and I think to have a long 40 to 60 year
old professional career that's
successful as long as you're learning in
year 1 3 7 9 12 patterns start becoming
more self-aware by yourself
understanding your strengths and
weaknesses you start having less just
busy work and more high-impact work
that's what's happened in my career stop
multitasking like I used to do so many
different things I just actually work in
different jobs like do this do that
see the problem about multitasking some
people can do it but the problem is like
whatever you're doing like those
different things they're going to suffer
like you're going to do lots of
different things really badly so when I
make videos infinite waters I'm just
doing this like I do consultations I
just do that I don't do a whole lot but
I have a lot of concentrated focus on
one thing for a sustained period of time
which is why we bloom and block baby but
you don't want to do that D you like I
want to open up a gym Ralph a restaurant
too now I'm taking my kids for a walk
that I'm going cycling then I'm going to
the beach then I'm doing this then I'm
doing that then I'm doing like good
gracious you're giving yourself way too
much to do
you're making it harder than it has to
be and that's why you lose the
enthusiasm for what you want to do so
you don't end up becoming productive at
all so to become more productive just do
one thing and do it well or just have
fun doing it whatever you want to do I
have a lot of thoughts on productivity
I've talked a lot about on this channel
whether we're talking about bringing on
a team or chunk in your days and doing
different things in different days or
not checking email and not having a
phone some of the crazier things that I
do to stay productive and do as much
work as I do in
both my businesses now but today I
actually want to talk about mindset I
think the mindset is super important is
extremely critical if you are thinking
about how do I be productive because you
have had really productive date you've
had days where you've watched a video or
something set you up you had a
conversation or you read a book or
something happen and you are on fire for
the rest of the day and then you wake up
the next day and that that feeling is
gone and you're not as productive and
even if you follow all the strategies
you're applying the tactic you say
you're going to do this this day you say
you're not going to check your phone you
say you're gonna bring on a team you say
you're going to apply this schedule and
chunk your time all of these ideas you
don't always go and do them because you
have the wrong mindset because you're
not in the zone and so for me what I
want to do and what I try to do in my
life and I encourage you to do in yours
is set up that proper mindset every
single morning and I'm actually touching
on this in the next book that I started
writing is creating that morning routine
creating that morning ritual that gets
you alive every day so instead of
randomly coming across it maybe you
watch this video and you get inspired
that's great but what do you do every
single day because I don't want it to
happen on four o'clock on a Friday
afternoon I wanted to happen at 7:30
every morning every day so that I'm set
for an amazing productive day every
single day you can design that instead
of just reacting to what comes into you
and so one of the things that I do is I
have a dealer reminder and I wrote
myself a quick note on what I want to
feel every day where I may hold myself
back my own limitation reminding me to
play a bigger game and I'll read it you
this is what I read to myself three
times in the morning before I go off and
start everything else that I have to do
maybe you'll like it if you want this is
mine today I will push myself to be my
absolute best to believe more care more
and try harder I vow not to let
distraction schedule changes or fear
prevent me from being great I will make
every minute count because my time is
running out I have the ability to change
the world and it's my responsibility to
do so three times I read that every
morning then I put on my music and then
I you know do a whole bunch of other
things
morning routine but it gets me set up
and that's what I want you to think
about think about what you do every
single morning because you don't wake up
pumped and energized right that alarm
clock went off you're waking up with the
start or whatever you're waking up most
people don't wake up super pumped and
energized even if you have a passion for
what you're doing and you're looking
forward to the day ahead you still have
to get out of bed and go do something
and I want you to figure out ways to
change your state and to go from that
luggage star into productivity as soon
as possible and so thinking about what
are the emotions that you want to be
feeling whether it's calm whether it's
excitement
whether it's happiness whether it's
ambition like what is it that you want
to feel in the morning that you want to
carry through to the rest of the day and
then what do you need to do every day to
feel that in the morning whether it's
listen to a podcast or reciting some
daily reminders listen to some music
reading a book watching a video
get you all that into yourself so you
set yourself up for an amazingly
productive day every single day by
design with intent with purpose to
create something amazing
so that's my take I made this video
because best you Pro asked me to so
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of believe life
leave it down in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd love to know what you took from this
video who has the most meaningful
message what you're going to immediately
apply to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
going to join the discussion if you also
want to add your own productivity hacks
that we didn't cover in this video
please share it I'm sure it'll be
extremely valuable for the entrepreneurs
watching this episode finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Jake on Jay
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting
that picture the tribute pictures to
your Instagram account I really really
really appreciate it so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
have an amazing day of pieces
how do you create room well one of the
things I uncovered over these 35 years
in developing really just unfolding this
methodology is that you get control with
five stages or five steps and there are
six horizons that we have commitments
that the more clarity you have at all
those six horizons the more you're going
to trust your judgments about what you
do and your priorities I couldn't get it
any simpler than this those five steps
pretty simple actually I didn't make
these up I recognize them right this is
how you get your kitchen under control
you get your company under control and
you get your consciousness under control
it doesn't happen by itself and if you
ever had your kitchen out of control
anybody ever come home and look like
your kitchen had been attacked oh my god
and you got friends coming over in an
hour and you're supposed to cook
spaghetti
oh no what's the first thing you did
besides drink or call out for dinner
first thing you did was you looked at
what was not right you identified
something that's not on cruise control
in that environment or ecosystem that's
you you you noticed what had your
attention right then what did you do you
decided what does that stuff mean oh
that's a dirty dish oh that's a spiced
oh that's a clean dish oh that's good
food oh that's bad food you clarified
exactly what those things are that are
not on cruise control then what did you
do
you organized them where they go you put
dirty dishes in the dishwasher you put
good food in the fridge
etc once you determine what it means you
parked it where it should go then what
you do you looked at the whole scene you
step back reflected on the whole Gestalt
looked at the time pulled out maybe a
recipe and then you pulled out butter
and started to melt it now that's how
you get your kitchen under control but
that's also how you get your
consciousness under control if I were to
sit down with you and you said God
things are feeling
overwhelming first thing I'm going to do
capture everything that has your
attention that takes one to six hours by
the way for most people just to identify
what got your mind then we're going to
go through each one of them decide
what's the very next action step
required for that thing and what's the
final outcome that you're committed to
finish about it the clarification step
then we're going to work with you to
customize how do I keep track of the
calls I need to make the errands I need
to run the stuff I need to talk to my
life partner about where do I put those
things so that my head is not trying to
do it by the way your head is a crappy
office anything you're trying to manage
just in your head believe me you will
over are under react to it if it's just
there that's one of the things that's
happened in the last 15 years since I
wrote the first edition of getting
things done is how much the cognitive
scientists have now validated the fact
that your head is for having ideas but
not for holding them as a matter of fact
if you're trying to hang on to more than
four meaningful things in your head
you're toast so building the external
brain requires that you capture the
stuff that has your attention clarify
actions and outcomes
organize the results of that in some
external trusted system so that you can
then step back and reflect on all of
that and then decide to have a beer
instead of any of it but that's a high
performance beer I'm not voting for
alcohol as a way of life I'm just self
disclosing I love good beer Poland's a
great place for that I've discovered so
that's those five steps by the way or
how we basically work with people what
we train people about and most people
even though these are simple have a huge
improvement opportunity in terms of
making sure that you externalize your
commitment at multiple levels so that
you can see them from where you need to
see them so what do you think holds
people back they know what they want to
do but they just can't keep the habit
they do it once and they follow up the
training and then next you want to do it
again and they follow the Train how do
you make that consistent well you just
keep you just keep working at it and
working it the best way of all district
planets in advance
instead of sitting down never start work
without a list and never start work
without prioritizing your list people
sit down and they say well before I make
a list of check a little email check a
little spam ascend something to my
friend see what's going on YouTube and
so on and so forth and then they look up
but it's ten o'clock and they haven't
got anything of value so what you do is
you have to say you know well well you
know whatever it whether they say that
if you started right it'll it'll work
out right so start it as week on your
most important tasks and do that until
it becomes a habit and here's an
interesting thing about checking email
is when you check email it triggers the
release of dopamine in your brain
dopamine is a drug but by the way
there's not all kinds of books and
articles and scientific studies on this
and dopamine is the same drug in cocaine
and what it does is it's triggered every
time you have a shiny object or
something new or different or
interesting or sparkling if a telephone
rings next to you you go ping your brain
releases endorphins and you can't hardly
wait to see what it is so you're talking
to somebody and you could be talking to
somebody about something very serious
and your telephone goes off ping your
whole mind goes blank because the middle
of conversation stops you've grabbed for
your phone you pick it up you look at it
you check it out everything else and
then you come back if you're working on
a task it takes an average of 17 minutes
to get back to the task and then there's
another distraction so another 17
minutes average adult is checking their
email between and their phone between 95
one hundred and forty five times a day
it's very easy which means they're like
attention deficit disorder dogs they're
just going to be running around back and
forth the whole day at the end of the
day they're exhausted by the way USA
Today and and Harvard approved that you
lose one IQ point for every hour where
you that you leave your email on at the
end of the day you've lost 10 IQ points
you actually become stupor throughout
the day
dumber and here's a ask this of my
audience as I say have you ever finished
today we don't think you've accomplished
you get an email responding to bings and
beeps and rings and so on all day at the
end of the day you go home and honey
says what do you want for dinner you
said I don't know I don't care anything
I just want to drink because you're so
exhausted you cannot even decide sit
there and basically like you've just
been you know punched in the side of the
head because your brain your brain is
bad and you lose 10 IQ points you get
stupider throughout the day you've got
to turn that darn thing off if you want
to remain sharp you go off the habit you
said what you do not to have it and I'm
going to give myself up my reward and my
reward will be to check my email after I
finished my first task so all a success
in life is task completion let me repeat
that I just had a long conversation with
an entrepreneur yamas fell off his chair
I was coaching him and he said he'd
never heard that before
and then I spoke to my pitch group I was
telling you in Japan I told them the
same thing and they were just
flabbergasted if the key to success in
life is task completion if you don't
complete tasks you have no future
and so if task completion is the key
then what you do is you complete more
and more important tasks and if you
start every day by completing a at the
most important task your brain actually
releases endorphins now endorphins is
another chemical and it's only released
when you do something that is life
enhancing and what that means is when
you do something that is good for you
that enhances your life that furthers
you it makes you happy it releases
energy it raises your self esteem it's
just sort of safe if you if you want to
be a winner how do you be a winner where
you win and winning means you cross the
finish line so if you start and complete
a task you're actually winning and you
get a feeling of being a winner which
gives you a suffusion of energy and
inspiration and it drives you and
motivates you to want to get that
feeling again so how do you get that
feeling again you start with another
task so I've developed the habit and
people who are successful you have to
habit of starting and completing tasks
so my wife comes in it says dinners in
five minutes so I look at my list
okay there's a five minute task and
whether you are start and complete
applied in the task and each time you
complete a task you get a burst of
endorsement the bigger the task the more
endorsement the more endorsements the
more quickly you become addicted to
starting a completely important task and
every single successful person has a
reputation for starting and completing
important tasks you want the job done
give it to him or her you want the
product served on time you'll have the
product completed you want the product
manufacture ship delivered give it to
him give it her and give it to that
company yes they always deliver that's
the best reputation you can have if you
want to get rich